يمكن أن يساعد تدليل القدمين في التخلص من
التوتر، ولكن قبل أن تعتني
بأصابع قدميك، قم بالبحث.
صحيًا، كن على
دراية بثلاثة أنواع من العدوى الفطرية
مثل قدم الرياضيين البكتيرية
لأظافر القدم أو وحدة أظافر القدم والفيروسية مثل
PL ثآليلنا إذا انتهى بك الأمر إلى
الإصابة بعدوى أي من هذه الأشياء،
فيمكن أن تتطور وتسبب عدوى أكثر خطورة
يقول رولاند الأول  ما يجب
فعله هو إجراء فحص مسبق للصالون والتأكد من
تعقيم الأدوات، وتريد
التأكد من تطهير الأوعية بين العملاء، كما
تقول، إن
التقنية المناسبة مهمة، حيث أن قص
أظافر القدم بشكل قصير للغاية يمكن أن يؤدي إلى
ظفر نام أو عدوى عندما يتعلق الأمر  إزالة القسوة تخطي
المكشطة المعدنية التي يمكن أن تقطع الجلد
وتخطي الحلاقة التي يمكن أن تسبب أيضًا جروحًا
تريد الانتظار لمدة 24 ساعة على الأقل
قبل الذهاب إلى الصالون وبدون
حلق ساقيك، تشمل علامات العدوى بياض
أظافر القدم الصفراء
أو المتقشرة  احمرار الأظافر المتفتت، الوردي
أو تورم الظفر راجع الطبيب إذا كان
لديك أي من هذه الأعراض
يوصي رولاند أيضًا بإعطاء أصابع قدميك فترة راحة،
انتظر لمدة أسبوع أو أسبوعين آخرين واترك إصبع
قدمك يتنفس بشكل أساسي
من أجل الصحة.